[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in a previous video
about the return of Mellie Otis I asked
you wonderful ladies and gentlemen to
type hashtag supreme hype in the
comments if you wanted to see me make a
video about the demon king and the
supreme deity
some of you responded so thank you for
that and because of your requests in
this video I will be looking at
everything we know so far about these
two incredibly powerful creatures I will
also be talking about what dark secrets
they might be hiding and what role the
demon king at the supreme deity might
still play in the story as the manga
ramps up for what is likely the final
epic showdown Before we jump right into
it I want to give a quick thank you to
black desert for sponsoring this video
black desert online is an MMORPG that
I've been playing for a few months and I
am very excited to announce that they
are now introducing shadow arena a new
battle royale mode that pits up to 50
players against each other in an epic
struggle to be the last man standing
shadow arena allows you to gather
supplies use your cunning and strategy
and destroy your enemies and of course
being the last man standing means that
you will be handsomely rewarded with
points and with glory shadow arena is a
really cool concept you start off as a
black spirit and you have to possess the
body of one of the playable characters
in black desert which makes the whole
thing even more suspenseful and exciting
right off the bat this game is a blast
to play with real-time action based
combat which includes fast paced combos
and diverse weapons and combat styles I
personally love the graphics and the
music and as a big fan of the fantasy
genre I thoroughly enjoy myself every
time I play black desert be sure to
click that link in the description and
check it out for yourself and of course
if you enjoy these videos you want to
see more videos like it you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime off roar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell needless
to say this video will look at all of
the information we have so far about the
demon king and the supreme deity and
that means that manga spoilers will be
coming so you have been warned
now the demon king and the supreme deity
are thought to be two of the most power
awful creatures in the entire seven
deadly sins series and their power is
set to be roughly on par with one
another the demon king is of course the
ruler of the demon clan and the supreme
deity is the ruler of the goddess clan
and not only are these two clans by far
the strongest out of all the clans at
races but they have also been in a
constant state of war with each other
for thousands of years it is important
to note that the demon king and the
supreme deity are referred to as gods on
multiple occasions in the story so they
are not just rulers in the sense that
Arthur is the ruler of Camelot or King
Bartra is the ruler of Leonys the same
goes for the fairy King although the
king of the fairy clan has certain
special abilities the fairy king is not
considered a god he is a member of the
fairy clan who was chosen by the sacred
tree to become king but he is not a
divine being or deity but with the demon
king and the supreme deity their power
appears to be on a whole other level
than the other members of their clans
when we first see him speaking to the
demon king in purgatory they usually
call Mel Yodas appears to tremble
although he tries to hide it the one and
only meliodas seems to be legitimately
intimidated by the demon king on top of
that the curses that the demon king and
the supreme deity placed on elisabeth
and meliodas show that these two
creatures have power over life and death
they are able to make meliodas
immortal and make elisabeth keep
reincarnating inside the body of a human
as far as we know no one other than the
demon king and the supreme deity could
have cast such a powerful curse and they
are the only ones who are able to remove
such a powerful curse the demon king is
the father of meliodas and zelgius and
he created the ten commandments by
dividing his own power in half and
granting 1/10 of that half to each of
the commandments this means that all Ten
Commandments put together will only
measure up to half of the demon Kings
power and that is before the demon king
spends eons inside purgatory where the
incredibly harsh conditions probably
make his body even stronger as was the
case with bond the demon king has a wide
variety of incredibly powerful demonic
abilities including the ruler a magical
power that lets him reverse all attacks
used against him so that instead of
hurting him they actually make him
stronger he can also manipulate the
elements use curses possessed
bodies of others like he did with
meliodas his body after meliodas
absorbed the commandments and so on
although we do not know the demon Kings
attack power level judging from
everything we've seen so far I think
that his power level has to be at least
over half a million and maybe even as
high as a million or more as the story
has gone on we've actually gotten to see
quite a bit of the demon king and his
powers and we've seen him in action
multiple times including in purgatory
and outside of purgatory once he takes
control of melioidosis body but compared
to the demon king we've seen almost
nothing from the supreme deity we know
that she is the ruler of the goddesses
and the mother of the goddess Elizabeth
she has the power to bestow Grace's upon
the Archangels to create nearly
unbreakable curses such as the ones that
were placed in Elizabeth Emily Otis to
control the elements and to destroy
entire cities she apparently has
immunity against all demonic curses and
in general the supreme deities abilities
are believed to have some form of
advantage against the demon clan because
light is thought to have an advantage
over darkness however because we haven't
seen the supreme deity in action we
don't know if this advantage would apply
to the demon king and realistically we
can't say whether the supreme deity is
stronger or weaker than the demon king
we just know that their power is roughly
comparable because we haven't seen very
much of her we don't have an exact power
level for the supreme deity all we know
is that she is believed to be residing
inside the celestial realm however we do
know that despite their insane power and
the fact that they are referred to as
gods rather than just mere rulers the
demon king and the supreme deity are not
all-powerful they're clearly not
omnipotent or a mission after all they
both wanted Merlin to come over to their
side during the holy war and if they
were all-powerful on their own they
wouldn't need her and the demon king
needed to use Hawke as a way to spy on
meliodas which means that he cannot
simply see and know everything he wants
to know on his own with that said the
supreme deity and the demon king do
appear to be practically immortal or at
the very least have an extremely long
lifespan and we know this because not
only have they been alive for thousands
of years but when we've take into
consideration how differently time
passes in purgatory we realize that the
demon king is still alive
despite living in purgatory for over 1.5
billion years in purgatory time
at this point we know a lot more about
the demon king than we did before
including his powers and abilities and
this is because the demon king has been
playing a major role in the story
recently but the same is not the case
for the supreme deity if you are
interested in how strong a demon king is
right now and if you want more
information in all his various powers
and abilities check out this video
called how strong is the demon king made
by my brother go Zen
I will link it in the description and at
the end of this video in terms of the
supreme deity she still hasn't played a
major role in any of the arcs of the
story we only know about her from brief
flashbacks so we can't speak to all her
powers and abilities or to exactly how
strong she might be but that very fact
begs another important question does the
fact that we still haven't seen much of
the supreme deity despite the fact that
she seems to be such an important and
powerful character mean that she will
indeed play a major role in the story
sometime in the future we just haven't
gotten to that part yeah will the seven
deadly sins be forced to challenge the
supreme deity at some point either after
they deal with the demon king or perhaps
she will emerge during the fight with
the demon king and the sins will have to
take on both of them in order to
speculate about this particular question
we have to think about where the demon
king and the supreme deity fit into the
story of the seven deadly sins are these
two something similar to the Olympian
gods in Greek mythology deities who are
extremely powerful but not omnipotent or
omniscient and deities who just like
humans have many character flaws and
these flaws lead them to wage countless
pointless holy wars if the demon king
and the supreme deity are corrupt and
flawed deities like many of the gods of
ancient Greece then it is possible that
in the final showdown Mele Otis and
Elisabeth will overthrow the demon king
and the supreme deity and take their
places as the rulers of the demon and
the goddess clan which would allow them
to finally end the pointless holy wars
between the clans in greek mythology we
have the example of the titans deities
who gave birth to the Olympian gods like
Zeus but were eventually overthrown by
their own children the god
of Olympus if the seven deadly sins
story is following this pattern then it
would make sense for the daughter of the
supreme deity and the son of the demon
king to overthrow their parents and
establish a new order in the world at
this point with everything we know about
the demon king it doesn't seem like he
will suddenly come to his senses and
become a good guy so the whole
overthrowing scenario sounds pretty
realistic there is a dark truth that we
have to keep in mind about the demon
king and the supreme deity they have led
their respective clans on a path of
constant war and they teach members of
their clans from a young age that the
other side is evil and deserves to be
exterminated judging by everything
they've done so far these are not the
type of rulers who can bring about a
peaceful world so replacing them with
someone else like meliodas and Elizabeth
seems like the only feasible solution
because Mellie Otis and Elizabeth are a
couple and in love if they became the
new rulers of the goddess and even clans
they would be able to lead by example
and bring the two clans together and
while we know that the demon king wants
to bring about death and despair because
he actually says so himself and so we
know he is not a good guy by any stretch
of the imagination we can't assume that
the supreme deity is necessarily any
better don't forget that members of the
goddess clan like Miele are taught from
childhood that demons are evil impure
creatures and that killing them is
actually doing them a favor according to
most of the goddess clan even demons who
did nothing wrong and our good kind and
caring individuals should be
exterminated and if anyone tries to help
them such as humans for example then
they should be exterminated as well
Jenna and zan arey were forced to
possess the bodies of humans and hide in
order to escape the goddess clan because
their decision to stop supporting the
holy war made them traitors in the eyes
of the goddesses and of course we know
that Elizabeth was cruelly and
mercilessly cursed just because she
dared to fall in love with a demon and
tried to help some demons instead of
destroying them all so from what we know
so far
both the demon king and the supreme
deity are obviously villains they are
powerful characters that need to be
defeated in order for the story to
progress and in order for the constant
holy wars to finally come
to an end one big question that has
always nagged at me is where did a demon
king and the supreme deity come from who
created them are they deities that
always existed since the beginning of
time or did someone create them at some
point were they actually weaker at one
point and became stronger or were they
born strong and were always destined to
lead their respective clans we don't
have any clear answers to these origin
questions other than the fact that the
demon king presumably comes from the
demon realm and the supreme deity
presumably comes from the celestial
realm
however we know next to nothing about
these two realms so that doesn't give us
much to go on there are also a lot of
theories about the true nature of the
relationship between the supreme deity
and the demon king something that they
might be brother and sister while others
think that they are former lovers who
became enemies potentially because the
demon king kept leaving the toilet seat
up or something along those lines but it
just makes sense for him to leave it up
since he has to raise it up and then put
it back down again
every time he needs to pee the supreme
deity should put it down when she needs
to use it and then put it back up the
demon king did nothing wrong
anyway as far as their origin story goes
the only real clue we have is the mother
of chaos if we go back to Greek
mythology for a second primordial
deities are the first gods and goddesses
born from the void of chaos chaos in
this case means the void that existed
before the physical world was created
and took the shape that it has not so in
Greek mythology the primordial deities
came first and then they gave birth to
the Titans and other creatures and the
Titans gave birth to the gods of Olympus
and eventually the gods of Olympus
overthrew the Titans darkness was born
out of chaos and light was then interned
born out of darkness so in the case of
Greek mythology both darkness associated
with the demon clan and light associated
with the goddess clan are born out of
chaos since according to Merlin the
mother of chaos has enough darkness that
she is feared by the demons while at the
same time having enough light that she
is revered by the goddesses it is
possible that the mother of chaos is
actually the mother of the entire
goddess and demon clans including the
supreme deity and the demon king perhaps
these two deities
were born from the mother of chaos but
then overthrew her at some point like
the Olympian gods did with the Titans in
Greek mythology and that would be why
the mother of chaos is now essentially
in hiding and cosplaying as the bore hat
bar if the mother of chaos turns out to
be that important to the story then we
may actually see her playing a key role
in ultimately defeating the demon king
in the supreme deity but we will have to
wait and see all in all it seems clear
to me that the demon king of the supreme
deity represent the dark past of the
world of the seven deadly sins they
teach hatred towards their enemies they
encourage war and bloodshed and they
treat their own children with cruelty
and malice the only way to bring peace
back to the world of Britannia will be
to either destroy or at least overthrow
the demon king and the supreme deity and
replaced them with more benevolent
rulers such as Elizabeth and Mellie Otis
the epic battle against the demon king
is already underway in the manga and we
will have to wait and see how the
supreme deity ends up playing into the
story but I am personally extremely
excited to find out what happens next
let me know what you guys think what are
the true origins of the demon king and
the supreme deity and do you think that
overthrowing them will be the only
option or do you see some other
potential solution to the constant war
and suffering also do you think that the
demon king and the supreme deity have a
relationship of any kind or are they
just completely separate rulers or
completely separate clans let me know
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell if you feel that videos like this
one provide value for you and you want
to support more you can check out our
patreon we recently revamped the whole
thing a big thank you to all the patrons
supporting us right now including our
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh and keelon and also our
newest patron ace 17 FF DP even donating
a single dollar will give you access to
our special page and only discord and
you will see your name appear in our
videos so please if you're interested
check us out link in the description
also don't forget to check out our
sponsor black desert a big thank you to
them once again as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us BAE
Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]